on va faire une interview nouveau
renault à la roma mais ce que le nouveau
renault a aussi arrêté les mon chéri à
l'alcool et le coq au vin
non allez mon chéri à l'alcool non
partage toute la soirée en vous
regardant je suis retire le chocolat
c'est toi est ce qui fait chier ses amis
quand ils boivent trop maintenant
non il n'est pas du genre à gâteau la
tête qu'il le sera avec la cigarette
j'espère parce que moi je le suis mais
est-ce qu'il n'est pas devenu chiant de
big boi plus non mais quand ils essayent
d'arrêter de fumer oui il a retrouvé sa
ligne
oui a nommé jean-pierre taxi arrêté
plume et même 50 c'est dire comment
j'étais mais l'accueil ton poids de
jean-pierre de quoi je me mêle de
plaintes sur le pack ok c'est quoi ton
pouvoir toi mon poids celui que tu veux
bien me donner
regarde ce que je te choque parce que je
trouve très affûté merci vous traînez
virage j'ai presque envie de te lécher
aurait annoncé plus tôt 95 80 je ne
réponds pas des questions idiotes pose
la question était elle en tyrie c'est
quoi ton poids plutôt aux 90 ha ben non
on peut on est la même chose 90 argent
roi religion j'ai honte parce que je
fais 1 m 79 en même temps je mesurais de
mètres cance voilà grâce mais compte
tenu de ma taille ces séries tu as pas
j'ai pas ça alors est ce qui va changer
renault par exemple est ce que est ce
qu'il trouve que sarkozy a fait un
travail utile quand il était ministre
je peux me dire que non il est pas
vraiment fan de sarko mais ce nouveau
renault par exemple est ce qu'ils jouent
en bourse par exemple non non non parce
que s qu'il a envoyé ses voeux margaret
thatcher par exemple c'est vraiment des
[ __ ] pour voir entre eux à cause
d'une chanson
est-ce qui s'est mis au golf le nouveau
renault non plus est-ce qu'ils portent
des jeans diesel à 300 euros maintenant
non télé - oui est ce qui s qui s'éclate
au champomy parce que sans alcool était
la plus belle quand même il vous plaît
le nouveau renault oui beaucoup mr
couilles par rapport à l'ancien modèle
j'y gagne
avec des extraits de chance et de
rothmans n a cure
dimanche jacques